I've spent the past seven years
traveling the world perfecting my craft
you see I'm something of a magician
inventor and chocolate maker so quiet up
and listen down nope scratch that
reverse it
Mr wonkara can say you're a man a great
engineering what are you doing
I'm making chocolate of course how do
you like it dark white nutty absolutely
insane many people have come here to
sell chocolate they've all been crushed
by the chocolate cartel you can't get a
shop without selling chocolate and you
can't sell chocolate without a shop
no daydreaming what are we gonna do
Willie
huh
double huh thanks on paper uh-huh I got
an idea
I know things haven't been easy for you
they're gonna get better you promise
Pinky Promise that's the most solemn vow
there is where do we start
where is this it's just cool what's
happening oh that's a chocolate that
makes it Fly let's find out shall we
who's forever job
nothing to see here just a small group
of people defying the laws of gravity
ladies and gentlemen of the gallery
Gourmet
my name is Willy Wonka
pretty sure I've gained about 150 pounds
in the last two weeks
change
all their lives
pretty good thing in this world started
with a dream
so you hold on to yours
there we go Mama
mark my words this is gonna be the
greatest chocolate shop the world has
ever seen
funny little man who's been following me
I will have you know that I am a
perfectly respectable size foreign
oh I don't think I want to hear that too
late I started dancing now once we've
started We Can't Stop